50 shades darker but actually this isn't
darker it's more romantic I would say
yeah I think that's probably true yes
but there's probably more sex in it
which Jamie doesn't speak let you do
that I mean like when your does the
director say more vocalization less
often words often so no one comes like
that
[Applause]
there's some scenes where they will-they
music maybe a bit of if it's a wide shot
and it's not like so it's the closest we
get the sort of kind of sort of just
sort of going for it in one piece and
they'll play music or something and my
temptation is always just to try to make
Dakota laugh so sometimes I'll do things
like when there's a moment where I meant
to you know orgasm because last time it
was you and sort of everyone else was a
woman the director or anything but this
time it's a it's a man directing that
lady's difference no not really to be
honest I mean I think whoever is tasked
with directing those kind of scenes I
mean you know these guys know it the sex
scenes are awkward anyway and it just
needs a very this is why I love him cuz
he includes me in yeah you know these
guys no sex scenes are just really hard
it's like no bad somebody no no no
might a bit of a couple of people under
that have it no no no he's always that
your decision no there's still time for
that
[Applause]
you
[Music]